[Music]
did kgp have a less than Stellar 2023
when Karen's at her best facts get
suppressed White House Press Secretary
Karen jeanpierre had plenty of memorable
moments from this year from clashing
with reporters to offering insight into
the president's thinking all done in her
own signature style and by signature
style I mean not answering questions
while repeating the same phrases over
and
over President Biden went to his house
in Wilmington what was he doing in there
I would refer you to the White House
Council Office so it was something
relating to this case I would refer you
to the White House council's office I
would refer you to the White House
council's office I I would refer you to
the White House council's office and I
would refer you to the White House
council's office I would refer you to
the White House council's office that
phrase will sure come in handy during
impeachment she also taught us that
sometimes you should try emphasizing a
different syllable especially
considering the president is doing
everything he can the president has done
everything that he can president is
doing everything that he can he is doing
everything that he can we will do
everything that we can I don't have a
policy update on that uh but I know to
tell you now as I've been saying we are
doing everything that we can possibly
we're going to continue to do everything
that we
can and everything that he can does not
include eventually finding his way off a
stage but hey when in doubt always
remember to trust the
process this is an ongoing process under
the review of the Department of Justice
we're going to respect the process um
and we're just going to allow the
process to continue process process the
process let the process continue it's an
ongoing process I am genuinely saying to
you there is an ongoing process this is
all part of the justice department
process as part of that process I said
because there was a process of Justice
throughout this process we just laid out
the process that was taken and that is
the
process trust the process I think that's
what they said about labotomy
Jim for someone one uh whose job it is
to answer questions like Karen
jeanpierre she's not very good at
answering questions is she you know this
job and it doesn't matter to me who's
President this is the worst job your job
is to stand in front of the entire free
world and defend a pathological liar you
have to you have to explain every stupid
thing they do every stupid thing they I
mean imagine was Mike MCC foret was
Clinton's like you imagine having that
gig you have to go up and explain to
people the phone rang he just put the
cigar down like have to
explain what these guys are doing so I I
think that she's irritating uh her her
method might be irritating but I think
that to have to defend this daughtering
idiot uh is a very very difficult job
and uh anyone who's who's got to be
white uh the White House Press Secretary
under Biden is GNA have a very difficult
time because he just kind of mopes
around uh so I don't I don't envy her at
all it's a terrible job yeah who was the
last one Jen saki right could you do
this I think you could do this job Emily
Austin I was about to completely
disagree with you I think this this is
the best job ever this girl gets to Glam
up sit in front of a camera and repeat
the same phrases over and over again I
don't know whose job I'm more jealous of
kamala's job who's to literally smile
and wave my favorite thing to do and
cackle or and cackle which is I'm good
at that too or just sit in front of the
entire world and just lie through your
teeth but she's not even being creative
with it she's not even trying to fool
America she's looking you in your eyes
and she does one of two things she
either just repeats the same phrase as
we saw
or my personal favorite she flips the
Uno reverse card and she asks you to
answer the question that you just asked
her yeah but my favorite lie I'm just
going to stick it in there is when she
said are you ready for this Biden has
the best border policy that America has
ever seen so she's not only a great liar
apparently she thinks she's a good
actress but she hasn't fooled us nick uh
go ahead
Nick obviously she's not good at her job
who do you think was better her or
well I kind of miss gen Circle back
yeah you know I kind of she circle
circle back cuz she would always Circle
back even though she never did yeah but
you didn't show any clips of Karen
janpierre walking in with like the
thousand pound binder yeah where if the
answer isn't in the talking points in
that binder then she'll just roll her
eyes and get mad and actually give the
reporters an attitude however when she's
the woke wonder of the White House we
were just talking about wokeism that's
what she is is let's be honest she she
is not competent for this position she
comes out there she gets relatively few
tough questions except for maybe Peter
Ducey Simon attiba and a handful of
others and she doesn't like to answer
those tough questions which is the Press
secretary's role they're supposed to
spin things I get that but it shows and
what this is a perfect example of why
you don't hire people based on certain
characteristics outside of Competency
she is the epitome of a Dei higher okay
but let's be honest that binder we know
is full of Biden's Doodles throughout
the day there's nothing there's nothing
serious in there well that makes it even
worse she's got the binder full of
answers and yes she's repeating the same
phrases over and over Joey uh the do you
even think that we need this kind of
position anymore uh you know I mean when
your job is to when you're doing a job
that you're following Kaye mckin you're
not going to look great doing it I know
I work at Fox right like because she's
brilliant she's really good at what she
does when she comes out with a binder
it's full of gotcha responses and and no
one likes it I I have pity on this woman
though she is a press secretary for
president she has a boss that boss is
the president the president has a boss
that's the Easter Bunny right and so
this man needs an Easter Bunny to help
him get around to tell him what's going
on and Easter Bunnies spend their time
dealing with kids and hiding eggs and so
they they have to talk in little short
sentences and say it over and over again
and so when you're working for a guy
that's getting that kind of Direction
She's just repeating what she hears man
maybe the EAS bunny should be the press
secretary look at her face look at her
she's winking at us she's telling us
what do you want me to say he's an idiot
I mean she knows that she is in a
helpless position I mean two months away
from doing an adult diaper commercial
what do you want her to say about him if
we if we had her phone every day it's
Googled can can a press secretary purger
themselves every day every day yeah I I
think this thing is a bit Antiquated now
we have YouTube I'm telling you if Trump
gets back in office he should do away
with this whole theater and every he
should put his iPhone on the the desk in
the Oval Office and he should give us an
update and go straight to the people I
don't think I'm supposed to say that
because I know people in the news
business love that press room because it
makes headlines hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else